[Musica]
immaginate di lavorare in un posto dove
la pensate come ai vostri colleghi
vi divertite un sacco immaginate di
lavorare in un posto dove si si discuta
e si litiga ma i pensieri gli obiettivi
l'etica quella profonda è la stessa per
tutti i colleghi e in più la sera invece
che tornare a casa vi piace rimanere lì
a bere qualcosa anzi chiamate anche a
casa ed iter aggiungetemi qui si prende
una birretta si sta qui perché il posto
dove lavorate è uno dei posti che
preferite di più al mondo un sogno no è
possibile immaginate di lavorare in un
social business dove tutti insieme si
combatte ogni giorno per salvare il
mondo chi ne fa parte dei matti dei
folli delle persone ambiziose e cercano
il successo ma allo stesso tempo
vogliono divulgare i diritti umani
vogliono fare la differenza certo vanno
controcorrente hanno molto coraggio sono
appunto dei folli voi vi direte ma chi
sono dei supereroi guadagnano salvando
il mondo hanno i superpoteri sono
raccomandati no sono come la maggior
parte degli adulti lavoratori in questa
sala sono come voi sono come me sono
specialisti sono
professionisti sono persone di talento
sicuramente sono professionisti del
marketing della comunicazione
ricercatori avvocati architetti grafici
sono
professionisti
cosa hanno fatto hanno scelto hanno
scelto di cambiare rotta
hanno scelto
uscire dal circolo vizioso del
neoliberalismo
del consumismo del capitalismo e voi vi
chiederete
basta scegliere si vi faccio degli
esempi un matto francese qualche anno fa
ha inventato una app io su questa app ci
faccio la spesa e voi mi direte esiste
già si esiste già ma questa non esisteva
perché io faccio la spesa da migliaia di
agricoltori biologici del mio territorio
li finanzia e gli do un canale per
commercializzare i loro prodotti
questo è un modo nuovo di muovere
l'economia in modo sostenibile si chiama
l'alveare dice sì forse molti di voi
l'ha già la utilizzano tutti i venerdì
arriva nel mio ufficio la mia spesa
un altro esempio oggi camminavo per
bologna una città che amo tantissimo e
avevo un paio di spa griglia bianche
l'ho comprato in un azienda che si
chiama toms l'ha inventata un matto si
chiama me kinski e quando era giovane un
po fricchettone andava in giro per
l'america latina e ha visto che alla
gente a tante persone
mancava tutto mancavano anche le scarpe
ha aperto un azienda e ha detto però
ogni paia di scarpe vendute io ne
tornerò un paio a chi ne ha bisogno
questa azienda esiste da dieci anni e ha
donato 17 milioni di scarpe questa
azienda cosa ancora più fantastica a 700
dipendenti è possibile questi
imprenditori ci credono tantissimo ed è
per quello che ci riescono certo come
tutti gli imprenditori hanno un grande
ego quindi se voi mettete insieme ego
utopia voglia di salvare il mondo
imprenditoria boom il miracolo può
succedere vi faccio altri esempi la
prossima settimana mia figlia che ha
fatto l'esame di terza media gli volevo
regalare un telefono l'ho ordinato in
una
un sito diciamo olandese questi matti
olandesi te li mandi il tuo vecchio
telefono e puoi acquistare lì un
telefono nuovo fatto al 70 per cento con
materiale riciclato prodotto totalmente
in europa anche loro hanno 200
dipendenti e nel loro sito c'è scritto
non mi interessa che università hai
fatto mi interessa il tuo talento e la
voglia di partecipare a questa follia
c'è anche scritto che pagano il 10 per
cento in più rispetto alle altre aziende
è possibile
questi imprenditori come ho detto ci
credono tantissimo e secondo me credono
nella poesia della vita e in questo
momento di poesia e di bellezza ce n'è
tantissima bisogno
la fuori il mondo è
terribile ce l'hanno detto fino adesso
nell'ultimo anno 89 milioni di persone
hanno migrato
la migrazione di queste persone dipende
principalmente da due fattori guerre
cambiamenti climatici migrano
principalmente da sud verso nord
le cause le conosciamo tutti
sicuramente una di queste sono queste
grandissime monocolture tutte coltivate
con la stessa specie il terreno si
impoverisce
non evapora più niente quindi smette di
piovere o il clima è violento basta
andare in pianura padana non bisogna
andare molto lontano
ecco le soluzioni
le conosciamo tutti
ce lo dicono da trent'anni la
biodiversità tanti semi di specie
diverse alberi di specie diverse piante
di specie diverse non tagliare più la
foresta magari anche una capretta una
gallina che ci camminano su morto e nel
tempo il terreno torna a essere ricco e
se lo si fa su grandi estensioni anche
il clima migliora e tanti contadini se
ne sono resi conto io ho conosciuto una
ragazza che si chiama angelin che vive
in ruanda
angelina è praticamente nata in un campo
di caffè cosa succede in ruanda le donne
colgono questi semine li portano in un
grande magazzino gli danno due lire e
partono per l'europa per l'america per
il nord del mondo angelina ha detto
basta e ha creato una cooperativa nel
2014 che oggi a
2mila 400 donne associate ma non solo ha
creato li ha anche la torrefazione hanno
fatto il pacchetto lo impacchettano lì e
hanno fatto un brand e il brand è delle
2mila 400 donne nessuno glielo può
portare via io l'ho trovato in germania
sugli scaffali del supermercato costa 25
euro al chilo
io l'ho comprato ma io per angelin ci
andrei a lavorare perché a 25 euro al
chilo un pacchetto di caffè nei negozi e
nei supermercati si vende bene
ecco quelle donne lì non migrano più
perché in ruanda sugli altipiani c'è un
clima meraviglioso è tropicale ha un
posto bellissimo quindi più reddito meno
migrazione quelle donne oggi guadagnano
il triplo rispetto a prima perché
angelin le paga il triplo
ecco invece ci dicono tutti che dobbiamo
coltivare migliaia di ettari in in
africa
soia mangime per questi allevamenti
intensivi in tutto il mondo un americano
deve mangiare tre hamburger alla
settimana questo si dicono ma in realtà
tutti i report delle nazioni unite
dell'università dei centri di ricerca ci
dicono l'opposto da vent'anni vi faccio
un altro esempio due mesi fa ero in
kenya lago vittoria posto bellissimo c'è
una piccola isoletta si chiama isola di
lusinga e lì ho conosciuto un ragazzo
che si chiama evans e evans come
angelina ha detto basta ha creato un
sacco di lì dai e distribuisce piante
miste ai contadini locali che anche loro
non migrano più perché vendono
localmente come i nostri amici
dell'alveare ma anche papaya avvocati
che vengono dagli alberi che hanno
piantato quindi di nuovo più reddito
meno migrazione è
possibile e ci sono queste aziende
esistono in tutto il mondo in asia in
europa in africa in america latina e un
sacco
che bellezza sono state fondate da donne
si è una magia ma funziona un'altra
bellissima che mi piace un sacco e
better books due ragazzi non avevano una
lira erano all'università raccoglievano
fisicamente libri usati e li rivendevano
hanno creato una piattaforma che negli
ultimi 10 anni ha rivenduto 300 milioni
di libri usati nel mondo hanno donato in
dieci anni 28 milioni di dollari per
aiutare i bambini a studiare in
tantissimi paesi del mondo hanno
200 dipendenti
molte di queste aziende vi siete mai
chiesti raccolgono milioni fanno aumenti
di capitale da milioni di euro ma hanno
sio che decidono di guadagnare qualche
milione in meno e che finanziano di più
prima di tutto i talenti che hanno ma la
causa per la quale combattono e per la
quale sono nati alcune di queste aziende
di soldi ne hanno fatti a palate questo
sistema funziona si chiamano unicorn
anzi nel nostro settore si chiamano
aziende sembra perché sono sia bianche e
nere sono aziende che fanno fatturato
che muovono l'economia in modo
sostenibile ma allo stesso tempo aiutano
il pianeta e le persone ormai è un dato
di fatto che i cambiamenti climatici
sono causati principalmente da consumi e
produzioni errate io oggi sono qui a
dirvi che questo può cambiare ma allora
quali sono i segreti dei social business
punto numero uno il fine il fine è
differente fino ad oggi le aziende
nascevano per creare lavoro per creare
economia
ma poi arrivava un momento in cui
l'azienda andava in crisi si risparmiava
poi l'azienda finalmente aveva successo
e il proprietario in diciamo card ai tag
decideva di fare quella che tutti
chiamano
filantropia ecco il social business
invece fin dal primo giorno fin da
quando è nato nasce con il fine di
aiutare il pianeta questa è la grande
differenza punto numero 2 che è quella
che io preferisco nei social business si
fa un sacco di festa ci si diverte sia
allo stesso obiettivo si lavora
tantissimo ma con entusiasmo i
proprietari i fondatori normalmente
condividono di più i propri utili
condividono le share con più facilità se
possono pagano anche di più i dipendenti
c'è proprio tutta un'altra atmosfera e
punto numero tre e che in realtà un
segreto non esiste per vendere un barile
di petrolio o un paio di scarpe
sostenibili le attività da fare sono le
stesse e devi avere un social media
manager devi avere un piano di
comunicazione deve impazzire a fare il
bilancio ogni anno le attività sono le
stesse è il fine che cambia e allora
giovani se volete cambiare il mondo se
volete fare la differenza
sappiate che una scelta non vale l'altra
sia quando si cerca un lavoro sia quando
si fanno degli acquisti perché alla fine
dei conti vivere in un mondo pieno di
plastica in un mondo dove l'aria è
irrespirabile
in un mondo dove milioni di persone ogni
giorno
migrano disperate verso un futuro nella
maggior parte dei casi fatto di
sofferenze allora visto che
l'opportunità se che le idee non mancano
finanziamo le facciamo parte di questo
grande cambiamento perché una società
più equa è possibile un'economia più
equa è possibile la scelta è nostra
grazie
[Applauso]